hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my flash episode 21 video
supremely weird in the best possible way
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet I think a really good
metaphor for this episode is that it's
like speedforce therapy so that berry
can cure the sad Affleck inside himself
get his powers back and I think it
offers a bit of a window into how they
might try and deal with zoom in the
finale this year but there's a whole
bunch of stuff we need to talk about not
least of which is how they avoid
explaining the speedforce it's a very
mystical explanation that they go with
but listen to top 10 WTF
I'll explain Easter eggs as we go along
there's a lot of stuff from the Wally
West era of comics in here as well as
flashpoint paradox so number 10 WTF the
runaway dinosaur explained the title of
the episode is taken from that childhood
book the story that he really loved
about how this dinosaur wanted to be
special but it had the most amazing
mother who was like you're not special
because of your abilities you're special
because you have the mother that's just
right for you who will always love you
so it was interesting then that iris was
like I always hated that book because my
mother was not that special mother so
Barry's the runaway dinosaur it was you
know very cry worthy episode just in
general so there are two big things that
I think that they did a little bit
differently with this episode that lent
itself to the people they chose to make
it so Kevin Smith told this story about
how he cried like a little girl when he
was watching the season 1 finale when
you know Barry's talking to his mother
he just you know just crying his eyes
out so think that's part of the reason
why he wanted to do an episode where
they got to address that where Barry got
to have that moment with his mother in
the screenwriter that they chose to
write the episode is known for writing
slightly weirder stories his name is axe
tense he wrote the screenplay for Thor
he wrote a lot on Fringe so you can
understand how those stories were you
know way weirder dealing with much more
metaphysical things that they normally
deal with on the flash I think that's
why they went after him to write this
episode instead of having one of the
regular writers do it number 9 WTF bit
of a deep cut deep space 9 wormhole
aliens speedforce wormhole aliens
anybody that was a big fan of deep space
9 probably thought that the minute they
started talking to him oh you're not
going home and I'm not Joe if you never
watched Star Trek Deep Space 9
there was this supernatural aspect to
the TV show where
cisco has special abilities because he's
born of this race of wormhole aliens
there's like a portal to another part of
the galaxy inside the portal lid these
supernatural beings so I like the way
that they played with the idea that the
Speed Force is alive and it's just
manifesting through these forms but
that's really where the comparison ends
that what they're applying with this
episode is that the Speed Force itself
has an intelligence there's there's
something behind it without outright
explaining it so a lot of you will shake
your fist and say oh they're not
explaining the mechanics of the Speed
Force but I actually think that's a
smart move on the writers part because I
think it's better that they treat it in
this weird emotional weight like they
tell this emotional story than to try
and over explain it on a technical
logical level and completely fail at it
so they're kind of stepping around the
problem and also kind of leaving a place
for them to go on season 3 if they want
to continue to explore how the Speed
Force works but for now it's just this
really fun weird story so you can take
whatever interpretation you want Barry
got his powers back because he probably
never lost them in the first place so it
was more of a mental thing that was kind
of the interpretation that I took
but number 8 WTF is flashpoint paradox
if you've never read that comic book
storyline or you never saw the animated
movie Barry has to come to terms with
his mother's death and that's what plays
out over the course of that story in the
original timeline of that story he goes
back in time and saves his mother from
being murdered by the reverse-flash but
because of that it destroys the future
everything gets thrown into chaos the
world almost collapses under this
metahuman war
so Barry realizes that in order to fix
everything he has to allow his mother to
die so he has to come to terms with that
so like this comic book panel here is
him coming to terms with that him
actually speaking to her in the past
look mom I had the opportunity to save
you and she talks him through it Star
Trek style the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few
a lot of you will probably walk away
really liking that moment with iris
where she's like come home to me just
because it looks so amazing but this
actually the scene with his mother where
he's telling the story of the runaway
dinosaur is my new favorite Barry scene
but number seven WTF zombie girder is
back zombies for real this was a lot of
fun they use this kind of eggs like the
pressure relief valve the comedy
storyline that then turned various
Arius when they needed to get buried
back at the end of the episode but for
most of it is just used for comedy and
they did a good job of syncing it up
with Berry's Ark girder Henry Allen's
story about the convict that the people
that are stuck on this one thing they
keep going back to four girder it's iris
for the guy Henry knew in prison it was
his old girlfriend for Barry he's stuck
on his mother's murder he can't move
past it so when resolving those
storylines Barry makes peace with his
mother's murder and then finally helps
girder be at peace but I know a lot of
you will wonder like the mechanics of
him being zombified is it blackest
night' weirdness no it's none of that I
mean you could look at it as like a hat
tip to blackest night but I don't think
it's anywhere close to that I think they
just used the dark matter explosion as a
way to show that he was somehow like
electrically charged and that woke him
up the dark matter is another one of
those Speed Force explainer things that
they do where they don't really explain
it they just use it to surface all kinds
of weird side effects like what's going
to happen to Wally West he was hit with
the blast but it seems like he doesn't
have Speed Force abilities Jesse quick
on the other hand number six WTF seems
like she's actually going to get some
real powers in that Speed Force
transferring at the end of the episode
was actually a big question mark like
what's happening here is he just waking
her up
is he transferring Speed Force so for
really deep cut in the late 80s and in
the 90s after Wally West became the main
flash the writers of the comic book
introduced the idea of the flashes
transferring Speed Force like people
taking Speed Force from other speedsters
and giving it to other speedsters so
they might be doing a version of that on
the TV show that might have been what we
just saw happen like I said the flash
plays it safe with the way they
explained things I think they're just
leaving themselves some story room to
work with like if they over explained it
now and they'd be locked into something
but if they come up with like a better
idea down the road I think they want to
leave themselves the opportunity to use
it so all we know now is that Harrison
wells said events are repeating
themselves just like when Barry was
struck the first time went into a coma
Barry zapped her with some Speed Force
and she woke up and seemed totally fine
like she wasn't crackling with lightning
or anything so I definitely think she's
going to have some version of powers but
it might not be exactly like Barry and
it might be temporary where Barry can
give Jessie quick in Wally West Speed
Force powers for a brief period like if
they needed them during a big battle
there's only two more episodes so I
think if they're going to do something
crazy like that we'll find out in next
week's episode number five though Cisco
can vibe across dimensions so he opens a
portal to the Speed Force using a
combination of things making me wonder
if this is going to be part of the
solution for zoom at the end of the
season because there are versions of
flash storylines where they defeat the
reverse-flash or they defeat the hunter
zolomon zoom like they find a way to
take their Speed Force powers away and
they just keep them locked up but
trapping them in the Speed Force is just
another example of that
so like I've said in my past couple of
videos there have been storylines where
speedsters disappear into the Speed
Force so that would be one solution for
zoom and the actor Teddy Sears the guy
that plays zoom is actually being cast
on the new 24 show on Fox
so that also might be a bit of a hat tip
to Henry Allen Jay Garrick man in the
iron mask reveal number 4 WTF definitely
sounds like we're going to be stuck with
him for a while now that doesn't mean
that he won't die in the finale but I do
want to believe that it's like a meta
way of saying that we'll get a version
of Jay Garrick that will be around for a
long time that will be him so even if
Henry Allen from Earth one dies Barry's
dad the real Jay Garrick would still be
around in perpetuity but number 3 WTF
big shipping moment this is like the
tumbler moment of the episode where iris
tells Barry to come home to her so it
seems like heading into season 3 they
will be a thing like it's one thing that
they've addressed their feelings for
each other but that doesn't mean they're
going to automatically move in together
start having children get married right
away well we'll have to wait and see if
it goes beyond that but if you're a big
fan of you know them doing comic book
stuff they've always been a big thing in
the comics it was actually one of the
few canonical relationships when number
two is real like the ultimatum zoom gave
to Caitlin either you're with me or
you're against me he's basically telling
her if she doesn't join Team zoom he's
going to kill her so while I don't want
to believe that she's gonna do anything
to harm her friends I do see a scenario
where she pretends to be on Team zoom
something bad ends up happening and it
drives a wedge between her and the group
and it creates this tension going to
season 3 there's just too many things
that have to happen in next week's
episode before we can start speculating
about where she's going in season 3 but
I don't think there's any version of
this where she would go against her
friends willingly and try to harm them
so she stays with zoom I think she's
gonna try and find a way to help tea
flash sabotaging but number one WTF
obviously is the evil metahuman Congress
in the police station the set design of
this is really awesome too you can see
why they want to zoom in the police
station
visually he looks kind of like this evil
God standing in front of all the gods
depicted like the Greek gods depicted on
the mural if you guys have never looked
at this it's kind of like the Greek god
version of the Justice League it's one
of the most beautiful set pieces that
they made for the flash during season
one but the other twist is that you get
the downward shot looking at like all
these metahumans that he's brought from
Earth to all the ones from Earth one
that have come so next week Battle
Royale
we finally saw Katie Cassidy as her evil
earth-2 metahuman version of herself I
think she's still called Laurel Lance
they may have changed the name but
effectively she's the metahuman version
of Black Canary which I know we kind of
wish she had been on arrow but they kind
of stuck their foot in the ground as far
as metahumans wet till Barry came along
and now it's only piecemeal so at least
we're getting a version of her I'll be
interested to see if they kill her off
in this episode because we know that
earth one Laurel Lance is not coming
back but that doesn't mean that earth
two metahuman Laurel Lance couldn't come
back in like a guest spot once or twice
a season so let me know what's your
favorite part of the episode like what's
your new favorite berry moment now I
still feel like his moment with his
mother in telling the story of the
runaway dinosaur that'll be good for a
cry like if you ever want to cry or you
want to make your friends cry just show
them that scene Easter eggs though big
Kevin Smith Easter eggs though as you
guys may have known Jason Mewes was a
guest star in this episode or he had a
couple cameos he was the guy coming out
a big belly burger this is crap is way
better in Star City which is an Easter
Egg for Jay and Silent Bob complaining
and he also shows up in this big
metahuman crowd shot but I only know
about it because Kevin Smith said that
he was in it because his face is covered
he's this guy here holding this giant
weapon so a couple really cool cameos
where there was any confusion I think
the resolution of Barry's arc at the end
of the episode is that he is back at a
hundred percent levels of Speed Force
but you watch the episode and you start
to understand why they picked Kevin
Smith for this one in particular because
he did ask to direct an episode he's
like hey I'm a big fan can I direct an
episode they felt like Kevin Smith
really understood the emotional arc that
Barry was on and that was the most
important part of this episode was
making you cry with that scene with his
mom but if I haven't said it before the
flash is like one of the best supremely
weird
as ever so I know everybody loves
giveaway so there is a new round of the
giveaway now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video there is a new episode of
arrow this week and new legends of
tomorrow why you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for all
my Captain America Civil War Easter eggs
and you can click here for my Game of
Thrones video from this week thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight